sure but like there's a lightness of
being that comes with laughter I mean
I've gotten sure like as you know I
spent the day with Elon today he just
gave me this burnt hair do you know what
this is I have no idea I'm sure there's
actually this it should be a human lab
episode on this it's a cologne that's
burnt hair and it's like supposedly a
really intense smell and it is to please
it's not gonna leave you or no that's
okay well that's okay I'll take a gentle
I'll whiff it as if I were yeah chemical
spray it on yourself because I don't
know if you can so I'm reading an
amazing book yeah called an immense
World by Ed young he won a Pulitzer for
uh we contain multitudes or something
like that I think it's the title of the
other book um and the first chapter is
all battle faction and the incredible
power that olfaction has
that smells terrible I mean it doesn't
leave you ah for those listening it
doesn't quite smell terrible it's just
intense and it stays with you
this this to me represents like just
laughing at the absurdity of it all so I
have to ask so you were rolling Jiu
Jitsu yeah with trains yeah so is that
fight between
um Elon and and azak actually gonna
happen I think Elon is a huge believer
of this idea of uh the most entertaining
outcome is the most likely
and he almost like there's
almost the sense that there's not a free
will and the universe has a kind of
deterministic
gravitational field pulling towards the
most fun
and he's just a player in that game so
from that perspective I think it seems
like something like that is inevitable
like like a little scrap in the parking
lot of uh Facebook or something like
exactly sorry meta yeah but it looks
like they're they're training for real
and Zuck has competed right in Jiu-Jitsu
so um I think he is approaching it as a
sport yeah Elon is approaching it as a
spectacle and I mean the way he talks
about it he's a huge fan of History he
talks about all the Warriors that have
fought throughout history if you look he
wants to really do it at the Coliseum
and you know the Coliseum is for 400
years I was there's so many so much
great writing about this
um I think over 400 000 people have died
in the Coliseum Gladiators so this is
this historic place that sheds so much
blood so much fear so much
anticipation of battle all of this so he
loves this kind of spectacle and also
the uh the meme of it the hilarious
absurdity of it the two Tech CEOs are
battling it out on sand in a place where
Gladiators fought to the death and then
Bears and Lions ate prisoners as part of
the execution process what's also going
to be an instance where Mark Zuckerberg
and Elon Musk has changed bodily fluids
they bleed this one thinks about
fighting you know I think it was in um
that book it's great book a Fighter's
heart where he talks about you know sort
of the intimacy of of sparring I have I
only rolled Jiu Jitsu with you once but
there was a period of time where I boxed
and um which I don't recommend
um I got hit I hit some guys and I
definitely got hit back
um it's more on Wednesday nights when I
lived on San Diego
um and
um you know when you spar with somebody
even if they hurt you especially if they
hurt you you know you see that person
afterwards and there's there's an
intimacy right you're it was it was in
that book Fire's heart where he explains
you know you're exchanging bodily fluids
with a stranger right and CR there's a
you're in your primitive mind and so
there's an intimacy there that that
persists so you go together through a
process of fear anxiety like yeah when
they get you you nod I mean you watch
somebody like catch somebody if you know
not so much in professional fighting but
if people are sparring that they catch
you you acknowledge that they caught you
like you got me there and on the flip
side of that so we trained and then
after that we played Diablo 4. I don't
know what that is I don't play video
games sorry but it's a video game so
it's like it's a um
you know pretty intense combat in the
video you're fighting like demons okay
last video game played was Mike Tyson's
punch out there you go that's pretty I
met him recently went on his podcast you
want you want wait it hasn't come out
yet oh it hasn't come yeah okay yeah I
asked um Mike
um his kids are great they came in
they're super smart kids goodness
gracious they ask great questions
um asked Mike what he did with the piece
of evander's ear that that he bit off
did you remember yeah he's like get back
to him here you go sorry about that he
sells Edibles that are in the shape of
ears with a little bite out of it
um yeah that his his life has been
incredible he's um uh and I met yeah he
he his family you get the sense that
they're really a great family they're
really um Mike Tyson that's a heck of a
journey right there of a man yeah my now
friend Tim Armstrong like I said at
least hearing from Ramsey he put it best
he said you know that Mike Tyson's life
is you know Shakespearean and you know
down up down up and just that the arcs
of his life are just like sort of an
only in America kind of tale too right